mimet you guys moved out of manhattan is
that right
yeah we're not in manhattan anymore you
got to hear this this is really great
where mimet is now there's some girl
next door to him
she's like running around naked by her
window right
yeah well yes i did see a a girl outside
of my window one time
get naked and my girlfriend's not happy
about it but i i don't think it's as big
of a deal as she does
the girl's super hot right well i i i i
have to be careful what i say uh she's
fine you know she she lives across the
way
and she's a nice person seemingly and
you know
you've met her i'm just she looks
pleasant
what do you
the problem was i didn't immediately
tell her
about it my you know living girlfriend
and later i happened to casually mention
i had seen this girl naked across the
street
dancing around and she said oh why
didn't you tell me and i got flustered
and i
i lied and i was like oh i forgot to
tell you in the moment but
my thinking was like i'd be a creep to
immediately run to my girlfriend and say
hey
naked chick across the way does that
make sense you played it wrong
you played yeah you that doesn't sound
creepy at all if you run from the window
and say oh my god there's a naked woman
out there howard
what's going on with matt he's sweating
he took a tissue
no you're funny because you're always
like nobody's gonna tell me what to do
now you're like terrified you're
terrified so you've seen this more than
once
that's what's going on i only saw her
naked one time and i
you know of course immediately looked
away i just didn't tell my girlfriend
about it
you're immediately looking yourself away
from that window
no wonder your girlfriend thinks you're
a [ __ ] artist you didn't immediately
look away
i didn't sit there and stay there no i
wouldn't do that
i mean right you went back to reading
your book okay he bought a telescope
how to get back to my work desk is right
next to the
[Music]
what a window where is mary let's get
her in here and let's get this
settled yeah mary
mary you think something's going on
right this girl is hot
she's dancing around naked and this is a
potential problem
if mamet continues to look out the
window he could build a fantasy life and
that's what we're trying to prevent is
that correct
it's correct and i was worried about the
quality of his work you know when he's
distracted looking out the window
right you're doing the show she's out
there right now has production
dropped in met circle i don't know if he
told you about my view out my window
but there's a man that urinates three
times a day and it's
orange and it's just painful to watch
and it takes about six minutes
where do you guys live yeah where did
you wind
up this time mary you're being serious
there's a guy outside your window
who is peeing in front of you and the
thing is he doesn't go up against a wall
or anything he like
faces the window it's like he wants
people to see a logical
thing to to ease the situation would be
to switch officers so that momet could
look at this guy's penis and you could
see this naked girl which wouldn't even
matter to you these are just things you
go through when you live in new york
city
i never had any of these things happen
well next time there's a naked woman out
there take my advice
include mary in it and she'll laugh and
if it's so innocent yeah go get mary and
say
look here's what she does that's wisdom
that comes with age
you know i that i am learning these
things